my name is Tanya Clemons mother I'm a
composer from Germany and I'm currently
doing an Erasmus plus exchange at the
Conservatoire of Tbilisi in Georgia we
heard about the possibility to go to
Georgia for Erasmus I was like wow
Georgia like I was interested that it
was totally new for me and I heard about
like the traditional music of Georgia is
part of the UNESCO so I just wanted to
be surprised actually and it's what also
really happened when I came here my
first impression was very colorful if
you go by taxi through the city and
there are so many lights you know like
green and blue it really looks amazing
those friends I made in the first days
here in Georgia I'm pretty sure that
they will be friends for me many of our
students study abroad
thank to recent opportunity of Erasmus
plus and we're proud of our foreign
students from the European Union living
in Georgia is a really safe place I
never had this experience of fear there
like so many bars and clubs and of
course they have one of the most
interesting wines I tasted ever
[Music]
you